ja das war wegen brocken vermisst auch
so ein bisschen die wollten dass in kiel
aber doch nicht
hallo ich meine lieben freunde weiter
geht's mit christmas kraft in der
letzten folge bin ich durchkomme
gestorben im kampf weil er mich in die
lava geschossen hat das war ein bisschen
ungünstig meinerseits jetzt geht alles
langweilig im ersten kampf ab ich ihn
besiegt aber jetzt wenn ich dann
ankommen dann bezieht er mich also mal
drankommt und kämpfen will der verkackt
irgendwie immer hier erst das stimmt
auch wieder so eine regel aber ich bin
mein haus trotzdem mega geil ich finde
das richtig schön weiß nicht wie gefällt
das
also ich fand ein haus auch schon muss
ich aber ehrlicherweise mal sagen
richtig geil bis jetzt bitteschön auch
der eingangsbereich der gefällt mir
löwenzahn
mal schauen ob wir uns heute noch mal
über den weg laufen oder eher nicht
hast du überhaupt eine idee überhaupt
nicht nach hause gerade sollte die
koordinaten schreiben ja er sollte nicht
rollen dabei warte schreibe sie mal eben
das ist einmal zehn und 331 e klasse
ein bisschen weit weg aber okay gut ich
komme direkt ul mal entgegen
obwohl nie komme ich lasst ihn nach
hause wandern ich werde euch danke bitte
schön
ich werde ich werde stattdessen erst mal
meinem haus weiterbauen ich meine du
hast da schon so was schönes gebaut da
muss ich doch jetzt auch nach nachziehen
und auch mal was schönes zu bauen das
was möchtest du denn da möchte die
globale sagen auf jeden fall kein chlor
ist kein idiot
das ist einfach viel zu schwer für mich
und hatte am schneemann gesehen so runde
form in minecraft born ist nicht
wirklich das war für mich deswegen
dachte ich mir einfach so ein
stinknormales haus so eine art wie dahin
zu müssen
natürlich möchte ich damit ich sagen das
seien sehr wichtig normales nein du
musst das eigenes bauen ja mach ich doch
das mache ich fand ja die idee von dem
megaprojekt horst damals richtig geiler
mit man da so hoch gehen konnten das
dann solche verhelfen er genau auf das
schätzen wir jetzt anfangen gewissen ja
das war wegen brocken fans auch so ein
bisschen die wollten das irgendwie
aber doch nicht leider nicht leider darf
ich ja genau beachtet aber mich wie geil
ist das nur ein teil kann mich wo ich
hatte angst davor hätte deal aber noch
ein bisschen mehr gebrannt
oha wollte der nicht hinterherlaufen ich
werde mich so hat hinterhältig das
überraschungsmoment oder kam diese blöde
spinde wenn ich finde nicht gekommen
wärst du tot gewesen
ja das trinkst du hast einfach einmal da
sind wir uns alle weil das christlich
ist karg entwickelt aber ich bin es
eigentlich viel spaß das macht voll spaß
ich bin ein drittel haben wir hier plus
bauelemente so hat doch auch mal was
oder aus mainz
junge entlastet doch kommen soll jedoch
etwas ist doch langweilig alter die
ganze zeit ist auch langweilig man junge
sei das war für eben gerade du hast mich
angegriffen hält man kommt immer wieder
an alter was heißt eigentlich gilt
eigentlich muss ich nachlegen wenn du
immer wieder ankommt ist das ausschalten
wenn wir noch immer wieder ankommen ja
genau alter mann in einem kriegs projekt
würdest du jetzt aber stelle aber das
ist doch auch kaka alter wenn man ja
wieder 2007 nicht angreifen was machst
du überraschungsmoment ausnutze so
richtig hinterhältig und mich angreift
jaja es besser sondern sich gerade
generiert und gegen den anderen kämpft
und an seinem haus weiter bauen will
ich hatte die spinne hinter mir nee ich
baue jetzt ein haus weiter
du kannst ja gerne tätig wir auf frische
dann wiederum gehen als traue mir wenn
du mich einmal angreifst ich greife
zurück an bis ich gewonnen habe
so aber wie gesagt ich mache jetzt nicht
weiter es liegt in deiner hand
nein ich glaube ich werde jetzt ich
wollte eigentlich ein element töten
damit die verzauberung tisch machen kann
oder so wenn nein dann kommt gomez
zwischenhalt bei zauberers tisch durch
den ändern wenn genau man braucht doch
nein braucht man eine tabelle und noch
keinen lage an den ozeanen der mann den
diamanten der obsidian wenn ich okay
ok
das ist auch bei mir relativ blöd gerade
gelaufen weil ich habe hier richtig viel
holz aber von einer anderen farbe als
jetzt schon mal ein haus so im grunde
ist aber egal ich hab viel hat ja noch
nicht erreicht hat einfach noch mal an
und wie geht's schnauze der krieg sei
besser englisch krieg aus orden du bei
mir auch ich bin der roboter papa papa
ich bin der roboter du bist nicht witzig
und du auch nicht drauf du bist nicht
witzig du hast kannst du mir vielleicht
einen seidel 1 ich brauche das führen
wolle blog geschäft ging fleisch ja okay
ich gebe dir ein gebratenes fleisch fünf
seite so viel seide habe ich nicht hab
nur einen seite ja dann kriegst du auch
noch ein normales fleisch okay kommt
einfach vorbei
aber klar das war chinesisch heißt
schnell schnell sie wissen das und fiel
hinter deinem haus aber jetzt nicht
genau wie ganz vorsichtig vorgehen man
da gewehr immer wieder recht mit ihm
geschäfte gut verbündet und so richtig
gut war vor drei folgen
ach wie schön hier gemeinsam in einem
haus wohnen gemeinsam höhlen beschert
hoffmann zieht auseinander dass auf
einer mega verfallen und kommen sogar
noch kein feedback erhalten können jetzt
ja da plötzlich so warum müsst ihr euch
nur über zerstreiten könnte dich einfach
in frieden zusammen christmas kraft
spielen
dabei ist alles doof ich bin sowas von
holz fans so ich habe ihm auf twitter
posten sortiment kam dann ist wieder
nacht weil es wäre nach das dauert noch
mancher findet bestimmt noch warum post
nach
eure geilste schneeballschlacht es so
lange her wir hatten nie so richtig wie
haben uns nie so getroffen und haben
schneeballschlacht gemacht irgendwie
richtig traurig welche wenige macht nie
in meiner schule so den pausen und so
was alles ist doch auch schon eine coole
schneeballschlacht naja kommt drauf an
halten aber ja es war auf jeden ist es
auf jeden fall immer witzig gewesen ihr
beispiel des schachtes cool wenn man so
cool gestaltet also ich weiß noch von
meinem einer schneeballschlacht ruhig
dabei war da waren wir über 2 gegen
einen nachmittag im winter und nur
logisch und ich dachte ja wir hatten uns
damit ganz vielen anderen leuten mit ein
ganz franken dann einfach ab redet und
hatten dann halt zwei teams gebildet
haben dann da das schönste
schneeballschlacht gemacht da waren wir
aber schon keine ahnung bestimmt 20
leute das war schon recht lustig das
hätte ich ja gut wir waren auch immer so
20 leute aber bei uns war das halt nicht
so dass wir es verabredet haben sondern
zwar immer noch den pausen hat man auch
immer wieder ärger bekommen bei
schneeballschlacht man ihm verboten seit
sich dabei uns eine die nase verbrauchen
gebrochen hat so etwas kann ja auch
schon mal leicht passieren wenn man also
ein heftigen schnee dagegen bekommt er
dann auch noch das eis besteht oder
irgendwie sowas ja ja solche wirft
nämlich nur luca ja die kommen immer nur
von oder voll ist schön stückchen 1
gegen die fresse ja das richtig schön
vanilla als gold wert
dann hat man gedacht feiern dann machen
wir das aber trotzdem weil die sind ja
die bergbau ist ja etwas erkannt
ihr kennt das lied nicht doch klar nähe
ich kenne nicht wert holzmeister okay
nicht ich bin total an einer musik
vorbeigeschrammt
du bist doch erst elf jahre alt das lief
doch davor vor fünf jahren noch nicht so
wie ich es 11 jahre alt ja bin 5 ok
es sind ja im gleichen alter nicht mehr
später tierärztin werden
was ist also wichtig dass mein
lebenstraum er wirklich ich glaube du
wolltest du später früher mal tierarzt
oder so wer nein ich habe kartenblatt
kaputt gemacht jetzt muss er wieder
neues plattform unglaublich traurig ich
hatte so was wenn du mein schaffen was
verbaut und das den blog so gar nicht
dabei sind so first world problems
jetzt muss ich hier wieder nehmen wir da
oben hin laufen ist das traurig eure
besten weihnachtsgeschenke nach was du
dein bestes weihnachtsgeschenk was ich
für mich war da was ich gegeben habe ich
denke mal was man bekommen hat oder wir
können der nächsten folge darüber reden
was man jemanden gegeben haben bei mir
war es ein iphone
ich finde jetzt muss ich mal ein wenig
voraus holen das kann man immer schön
von den zeiten her vergleichen früher
war auf jeden fall wenn ich da so eine
große playmobil piratenschiff bekommen
das war einfach der traum hat mal am
selben ort noch schön was einem zum
basteln gehabt das war geil ganz ehrlich
da man richtig schöner ich bastel und
das war einfach der größte traum und
wenn deren erfüllung gingen dann border
war es mal auch unter freunden badboy
bei die teile manchmal auch schwimmen
konnten zum teil hatte ich das konnte
ich mich fühlte mich so krass
mittlerweile hat sich das die darüber
hatten wir auch schon geredet hat sie
alle so wenig geändert von den wünschen
sag ich mal und so das geschenk was ich
wo ich wirklich sagen das war das beste
so den letzten jahres war
na ja letztes jahr in computer der war
für mich da war ich noch was besonderes
jetzt habe ich mir mal zwischendurch
einen computer gekauft
letztes jahr war schon wirklich da
computer ganz schön für mich immer die
falschen
hier alltag ich lauf hier im kreis an
wie ich verstehe es nicht mehr aber mein
haus finde ich nie wieder
das ist unglaublich immer weil ich
irgendwie nur 150 meter weiter gehe
da will ich wieder zurückkommen möchte
ich finde es einfach nicht ich verkaufe
ich immer diese schnee gegenden
früher habe ich dir geliebt mittlerweile
durch christus kraftvoll die kacke
geworden
wir haben auch war gar nicht mehr so
viel zeit eventuell ja was war mein
bestes geschenk was ich hier hatte
iphone hast du hast gesagt ja aber dass
das jetzt ich meine so oft auf damals
bezogen jetzt
ach so ja auch damals bezogen würde ich
sagen deine meinung ist ja gar nicht
gefragt ja du hast doch hier nur weil
jemand einen mops witzig komme er sollte
auch total witzig werden
ja mein schönstes geschenk damals war
halt sondern wir hatten so einen lego
rennen holte damit kommt man dann auch
so rennen fahren und sonst bietet hatte
ich auch mal wo man dann so oft sie mit
so fahren troja oder also nur ein paar
sänger des flugzeugs so was hatte ich
wenn manchmal bei dem thema solche
sachen oder sowas heute der inhalt aus
kall
und weil sie nicht also bei mir war es
auch so dass oma und opa schenken die
bei dir immer so heftige sachen oder
mehr so schränken den dich unbedingt
etwas heftig als immer so wenn ein
bisschen geld oder so dass oma und opa
die geschenke selber kaufen oder pizza
den tories ein feigling junge was willst
du dich ich wollten wir heute bis
schuldig davon wie geil einfach immer
weg das ist sehr traurig vor allem
nützlich volk vertreten dass ich da
irgendwie beim thema bleibe ja das
kannst du das macht spaß komme ja das
ist grün
ja hallo ich hab dich hab ich hab dich
zweimal getroffen kann wie geil ist das
denn
warum hast du dein bett gesteckt warum
denn nicht
ach komm echtholz ab es ist langweilig
wenn es einen fairen kampf hat ja ja ja
von den bogen überhaupt geklappt hat
cool cool
ich treffe einfach jedes mal wie geil
ist das bitte schön
der junge mann das ist schon total
langweilig wenn du nur mit bogen machst
ist einfach nur geil weil mit dem bogen
es ist mega langweilig wenn man nur mit
was rede ich viele pfeile einfach mal
verschluss junge das ist mega langweilig
wenn man mit bogen macht also habe ich
echt keinen bock als ehrlich wenn dann
nur auch egal
das war ein zug an wo ist ich habe mir
in bogen gebaut ich wollte feiern habe
das alles nichts erreicht wird nicht
erreicht erreichten diesem projekt du
hast kein haus du hast meine sachen alle
sachen die nur von lyon ist bitteschön
zu ende bauen wir der aiba abkommt und
ein versuche mit fragen zu beeinflussen
nur dann alle einfach oder einfach
eigentlich in ruhe das alles zu ende
bauen lässt man du bist auch schuld du
hast mich heut ist reingekommen ist ein
verzweifelter appell an die geburt und
nicht dann zu beschuldigen dass ich
entweder du hast du bist ja genau die
sachen nur von mir keine falsche
tatsachen und das einfach meine sachen
behalten
du hast meinen part abgebaut
du hast glaube ich dass kein blog dass
ein bett das ist ein blues harp die
regeln extra so definiert aber ich nicht
wollte dass du da die dann irgendwie
rein junge ich darf sein haus abfackeln
einfach wenig geeignet feldbett abgebaut
ist es regelt band ich ich hab sie ja
sogar hingesetzt wieder
ja aber das ist natürlich dass born
punkt weg und so weiter aber ist er halb
so wild
auch man all das kann nicht sein dass
zocker fünf rüstung von mir gerade mal
wieder alle neu gekauft damit meine
nächste wahl muss ich ein bisschen mit
detaillierter plan gehabt dass ich
irgendwas anderes contractors kampf ist
ja verdammt
ich möchte wenigstens ganz kurz den weg
zurückfinden zu meinen von meinhard oder
es ist ja gut meine lieben freunde wenn
es euch trotzdem gefallen hat könnt ihr
an daumen runter lassen sonst würde ich
sagen ich lege mich jetzt erstmal ein
bisschen rein das nicht überhaupt wenn
man's bonpoint ab und dann sehen wir uns
beim nächsten mal morgen auf gomez kanal
wieder ins auto rein schön mit